[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on va faire un petit exercice est ce que
vous pouvez tous ce soir fermé les yeux
et prend une grande respiration
vous êtes en 1960 en uruguay dans la
banlieue de montevideo et à côté de vous
il ya un petit enfant qui s'appelle juan
et qu'à 14 ans vous pouvez ouvrir les
yeux quand les militaires ranchi roanne
et réquisitionnent son vélo il est
effondré
pour lui le vélo c'était son seul
symbole de liberté sur sa selle il
oubliait la dictature l'oppression et la
délation
maintenant il n'a plus d'échappatoire il
veut lutter pour défendre son territoire
roanne a alors que 14 ans quand il
rejoint la révolution
prenant part à des opérations de
sabotage parfois violentes mais à l'âge
de 20 ans il doit fuir et part au brésil
là il refait sa vie et devient pilote
d'avion un jour dans le cockpit
il a une idée de génie il imagine une
chaussure qui pourrait rouler juan
invente la première chaussures à
roulettes
plus tard il inventera un jeu avec
lequel vous avez tous déjà probablement
jouer une sorte de grand resort qui
descend les escaliers tout seul avec ses
inventions juan fait le tour du monde et
devient millionnaire
mais rassurez vous l'histoire ne
s'arrête pas là saint-exupéry disais que
les grandes personnes ont d'abord été
des enfants mais peu d'entre elles s'en
souviennent juan devenu grand n'a pas
oublié le petit enfant qu'il était et se
met en tête de créer un vélo à son image
il y mettra vingt ans de sa vie toute
son énergie et toute sa fortune pour
réaliser ce vélo
maintenant regardez bien ce vélo parce
que ce n'est pas un simple vélo dans les
favelas brésiliennes
un homme a récupéré 200 bouteilles en
plastique dans les poubelles elles ont
ensuite été broyés fondu
et moulé pour en faire ce cadre un cadre
dont on peut changer la taille des roues
de manière à ce qu'on ait dix ans ou 25
ans on puisse garder le même vélo un
cadre garantie à vie qui produit à une
grande échelle coûterait seulement 20
euros
regardez bien ce vélo parce que ce n'est
pas un simple vélo c'est l'héritage
d'une philosophie
la philosophie du moins mais mieux la
philosophie de la sobriété heureuse
quand j'ai rencontré roanne dans son
petit atelier d'artiste à sao paulo j'ai
compris que vivre avec moins c'est vivre
plus léger et être plus heureux
mais messieurs bonsoir je m'appelle
mathieu vie de foot et l'an dernier juan
était la dernière rencontre lors de mon
tour du monde en vélo pendant un an avec
mon cousin quand tu invites foot on est
parti dans cinq continents et d'aller 18
mille kilomètres pour rencontrer et
transmettre les solutions les plus
innovantes face aux déchets plastiques
maintenant j'aimerais vous expliquer
pourquoi tous les deux on a décidé de
consacrer notre quotidien à cette cause
d'abord on a compris qu'on vivait dans
une économie linéaire en gros pour
produire cet appel tout pour produire un
gobelet en plastique
d'abord on extrait de la matière
première dont la transforme
on utilise quelques secondes pour un
gobelet par exemple et on la jette ce
qui pose de problèmes
d'un côté on a de moins en moins de
ressources
de l'autre on a plus en plus de déchets
est ce que vous savez combien de tonnes
de déchets finissent dans les océans
chaque minute
réfléchissez un petit chiffre dans votre
tête c'est 18 tonnes 18h c'est
l'équivalent en poids de 250 personnes à
peu près ça veut dire qu'en deux minutes
on remplissait tsan en une après-midi
ont rempli le stade de france et d'après
des scientifiques du cnrs déjà
aujourd'hui entre la corse et la toscane
il ya plus de plastique que de plancton
non quand on a appris qu'il existait un
autre modèle qui allie économie et
écologie
alors là on était passionné c'est un
modèle qui s'inspire de la nature dans
la nature
en gros il n'y a pas de déchets il ya
une utilisation efficace efficiente des
ressources
ce modèle s'appelle l'économie
circulaire et je vais vous donner
quelques exemples juillet 2010 est un
vendredi matin
on s'élance pas très loin d'ici
depuis en cours pour notre tour du monde
on commence par longer l'atlantique en
vélo et on arrive après quelques jours à
santander en espagne pour notre première
rencontre frédéric à berthod qui on
arrive chez elle trempé après une
journée sans la pluie je peux vous dire
c'était un moment fort parce que ça nous
faisait complètement bizarre frédéric à
cette chercheuse italienne connue dans
le monde entier
elle est passée sur la bbc elle est
passée sur cnn
elle nous accueille comme si on la
connaissait frédéric à cette chercheuse
italienne je les dis mais c'est aussi
une passionné d'apiculture et un jour
quand elle va chercher ses ruches elle
voit dans ces rues des larves blanche
qui ronge les alvéoles
alors ces alvéoles il s'avère qu'elles
ont une composition proche de celle du
plastique
elle amène donc les larves dans son
laboratoire et observe qu'au moment de
faire leur cocon ses larves arrivent à
biodégrader le plastique en quelques
semaines alors tout de suite moi je me
suis dit oh est ce que cette l'art se
serait pas le zidane de l'environnement
ce que c'est pas lui qui va nous
dribblait tous ces déchets plastiques
frédéric est nous rappelle qu'on vit
dans un écosystème et que bien sûr m des
larves partout perturberait cet
écosystème naturel son projet c'est de
répliquer de trouver l'embryon capable
de biodégrader plastique et le répliquer
en fait à grande échelle et moi ce qui
m'a vraiment inspirée chez frédéric à
c'est que les réponses aux problèmes
concrets et ben les trouvent lé cherche
dans la nature décembre 2017
après avoir pédalé 2000 km en europe on
s'envole pour remonter l'afrique de
l'est en vélo et là on lorsque des
baobabs géants au mozambique
on traverse des parcs naturels en
tanzanie et on arrive à la frontière du
rwanda alors à la frontière il ya les
douaniers qui cherche dans nos sacs
si on a des armes des drogues ou des
sacs plastiques
en effet le rwanda était un des premiers
pays au monde à bannir les sacs
plastiques dix ans avant la france
à votre avis qu'est-ce qu'ils utilisent
à la place ils utilisent les anciennes
copie d'étudiants qui sont pliés comme
des origamis et donc on peut trouver un
6 sur 20 dans lequel on va mettre son
oignons de sa pomme moi ce que je me
souvenais du rwanda est assez tristement
c'était le génocide des 94
mais j'étais surpris pendant les
premiers kilomètres de voir des collines
verdoyantes des paysages magnifiques
surtout des villes propres à kigali
surtout la capitale en gros kigali il
faut l'imaginer c'est la propreté de
singapour l'effervescence de marrakech
et le relief de san francisco en 20 ans
le rwanda est devenu le pays le plus
propre d'afrique notamment parce que son
président paul kagame a su lui donner
une vision environnementale et assure
respecter sa vision et c'est peut-être
ça finalement qui les rend innovants
c'est peut-être ça qui m'a marqué moi
c'est la capacité d'avoir une vision et
à oeuvrer collectivement pour y répondre
répondre à ce rêve avril 2018
on est à jakarta en indonésie
ici 9 plastique sur dix finissent
directement dans les océans mais david
lui ait pas d'accord avec ça et il
aimerait créer un emballage qui pourrait
lui retourner dans l'océan c'est pour ça
qu'il a créée la start up et vos mères
et à votre avis cet emballage que j'ai
ici j'ai ramené d'indonésie il est fait
à partir de quoi
je vous ai ni trois indices le premier
je crois que j'ai entendu mais je vais
quand même donné les trois indices pour
les autres le premier c'est que sa
production permet de capter du co2 donc
il lutte contre le réchauffement
climatique
le deuxième c'est qu'il est entièrement
soluble dans l'eau donc on n'a pas le
problème des déchets plastiques et le
troisième c'est qui permet à des
pêcheurs de sortir de la précarité c'est
bien des halles pour ceux qui avaient
encore un petit doute donc david il
travaille avec des pêcheurs locaux pour
cultiver ces algues les récupérer les
stocks et les sécher les compresser les
contacts et les couper et en fer
l'emballage qui est devant vous j'avais
dans ma main et donc c'est marrant on
était à jakarta hélas en bois noté par
exemple on met le sachet avec
l'emballage du sachet de thé qui on peut
boire le sachet ou bien imaginez vous
vous lavez les mains tranquille et puis
là le l'emballage du savon se dissout
dans l'eau
pour la petite histoire david il est
passé en trois ans de vendeurs au mcdo à
speaker ou world economic forum
bon mais ce qui m'a intéressé mois chez
david ce qui m'a inspiré vraiment c'est
qu'il a su voir dans l'héritage d'un
problème
l'opportunité d'une évolution l'héritage
du problème des déchets plastiques
l'opportunité de voir une solution
c'est ça qui me marque maintenant on est
en juillet 2018
je rentre de mon tour du monde avec en
tête la phrase de roanne aussi sa veyron
aussi l'inventeur du vélo dont je
parlais au début le vrai voyage commence
quand il se termine
qu'est ce que j'allais faire un mois
après avoir fugué cul tout ce tour du
monde et vécu toutes ces rencontres j'ai
rejoint une équipe de passionnés et
ensemble on fédère un réseau de 400
start up de l'économie circulaire et
toutes les semaines on forme des futurs
dirigeants à ce nouveau modèle et on
coqueret des projets entre des
multinationales et des start up des gens
comme juan frederica et david j'ai eu la
chance de rencontrer des centaines et
tous un jour se sont posés la question
qu'est ce que j'ai envie de laisser à
mes enfants
et c'est pas moins ici ce soir qui vais
vous dire ce que vous devez changer
votre quotidien parce que pour moi
toutes les solutions techniques elles
existent j'en ai donné quelques exemples
mais toutes les solutions pour moi elle
existe la vraie question c'est qu'est ce
que vous vous êtes prêt à mettre en
place
qu'est ce que vous vous êtes prêts à
changer dans votre quotidien dans votre
consommation dans votre vote à travers
toutes les actions vous pouvez faire
qu'est ce que vous êtes prêts à faire
car une chose est sûre une chose est
sûre
[Musique]
si nous continuons comme nous avançons
quand j'aurai l'âge de mes parents
ce sont 10 milliards sur terre
l'homme sera à l'animal mortifère quand
j'aurai l'âge de mes parents mes enfants
connaîtront l'enfer l'enfer d'un océan
de plastique l'enfer de guerre
climatique la sphère de quelques
sceptiques
alors je les regarderai dans les yeux
je leur dirai
qu'on n'a rien fait pour
en
[Musique]
hall armes citoyens formez vos
bataillons marchons
marchons
car le changement si on ne prend pas par
la main et nous prendra part la gorge
[Musique]
les solutions le monde en regorge dès
aujourd'hui
construisons notre demain c'est
l'histoire d'un millionnaire uruguayen
qui nous apprend que vivre avec moins
c'est être plus heureux c'est l'histoire
une chercheuse italienne qui trouve ses
réponses dans la nature c'est l'histoire
d'un leader africain qui reverdit un
pays c'est l'histoire d'un jeune
indonésien qui innovent pour évoluer
alors ce soir
demain matin l'année prochaine faisons
de ces apprentissages notre héritage qui
tels des bagages voyage à travers les
âges il ya cinq siècles rabelais
écrivait science sans conscience n'est
que ruine de l'âme de cyrine raviveront
la flamme et retenez ce message
messieurs et mesdames faisons de notre
âme notre sésame amis spectatrice à 1000
spectateurs
j'arrive à la fin de mon quart d'heure
mais j'ai avant de vous quitter
une dernière question à vous poser dans
ce monde que nous souhaitons meilleur
quel sera votre rôle en tant qu'acteur
merci
[Applaudissements]